c
ariane 20 sur 20 pour le lanceur
européen qui a placé en orbite à la
seconde prévue un satellite de
télévision ouest allemand air inter deux
pilotes dans l'airbus a320 pour la
direction 3 pour les syndicats de
pilotes la grève prévue pour mardi a été
déclaré illicite par le tribunal la
sphère de radio nostalgie le nom d'un
proche de charles hernu est prononcé
l'ancien ministre de la défense
socialiste estime que la coupe est
pleine
il le dira dans ce journal une journée
supplémentaire de détention pour marcel
carton
marcel fontaine jean paul kauffmann jean
louis normandin d'antenne 2 et roger
auque les otages français au liban n'ont
toujours pas été libérés dans la
monsieur bonsoir la science et la
technique française à l'honneur dans le
domaine spatial avec ariane et en
médecine avec une découverte sur le sida
voilà la une de l'actualité ce soir
l'espace d'abord la réussite du
lancement de la fusée ariane donne
beaucoup d'espoir à l'euro spatiale dont
notre pays on le sait est le principal
moteur le tir de la nuit dernière à la
base de kourou en guyane a eu lieu au
jour à l'heure est à la seconde prévue
le satellite de télévision ouest
allemand a été parfaitement placé en
orbite
seule petite ombre au tableau les
difficultés de mise en route de ce
satellite qui devrait révolutionner la
télévision européenne des années à venir
jacques violet sur un gong final 3 2 1
pour ariane le contrat est parfaitement
rempli en 21 minutes et 28 secondes
satellite livré à sa place la fusée
européenne peut avec des tirs comme
celui ci espérait prendre la moitié du
marché mondial des lancements de
satellites d'ici l'an 2000 seule fausse
note dans ce lancement le satellite
les techniciens allemands n'ont pas
réussi à déployer
l'un des deux panneaux solaires les
opérations pourtant répété cent fois
avant le lancement sur terre
télécommandés depuis le sol
cette ouverture est un problème
mécanique peut-être un simple ressort
coincé pour l'instant pas de panique on
va essayer à nouveau dans quelques jours
peut-être en exposant le côté défectueux
au soleil pour le réchauffer
théoriquement tv sat sera rejoint par
trois autres satellites identiques un
deuxième allemands et deux français
complétant le programme tdf un lancer au
printemps 88
la décision de lancer tdf2 sera prise
prochainement le gouvernement français
désirant un financement privé
pour la suite c'est l'avenir de la
télévision directe européenne qui est en
jeu si tout va bien
à partir de février 88 les allemands
d'abord ensuite plus de 100 millions
d'européens pourront recevoir des
émissions de télévision directement chez
eux dans chaque foyer avec une petite
antenne d'environ 50 cm après lé pari
technologique les grands enjeux
culturels
après les techniciens de l'espace des
médecins français à l'honneur donc la
recherche contre le sida vous le savez
fait l'objet d'une course scientifique
dans le monde
avec aussi en arrière plan des retombées
commerciales
c'est le professeur français guy
montagné qui avait le premier isolé le
virus
et c'est encore lui par l'intermédiaire
de l'une de ses équipes à strasbourg qui
vient de découvrir une protéine qui
pourrait empêcher il faut encore
employer le conditionnel le réveil du
virus du sida chez les séropositifs
autrement dit les personnes touchées par
la maladie
mais qu'ils n'ont pas encore développé
daniel lui les chercheurs français ont
peut-être trouvé la clé d'une des
principales énigmes que pose le virus du
sida
pourquoi chez certaines personnes le
virus sans dort-il alors que chez
d'autres il se réveille se développent
et provoque la maladie du sida en
faisant éclater les défenses
immunitaires
réponse il existerait dans la
programmation du virus un gène dont la
fonction est précisément de mettre en
sommeil l'activité du virus c'est le
jeune f
nous avons démontré que la protéine
correspondant à ce jeune f permet très
probablement au virus de rester caché
dans les lymphocytes infectés en
d'autres termes il permet au virus de
sommeiller et d'être totalement inactif
pendant temps comme vous le savez tu
peux être extrêmement long je vais
parler de quelques années d'autres
découvertes renforcent l'idée que le
jeune ait faim intervient effectivement
dans l'activité du virus
son identité est semblable à celles
d'autres jeunes qu'on appelle des
oncogènes et qui sont responsables de
cancers chez l'homme et chez l'animal en
provoquant une multiplication anarchique
des cellules dans le cas du virus les
faits seraient simplement contraire il
diminuerait la multiplication du virus
si l'hypothèse se vérifie la découverte
est majeure elle pourrait déboucher sur
un traitement et peut-être même sur un
vaccin
certes il faut rester prudent mais la
recherche aujourd'hui donnent des
raisons de rester optimistes
la grève de mardi prochain prévu par les
pilotes et mécaniciens d'air inter a été
jugée illicite par le tribunal de
bobigny en l'occurrence les juges ont
estimé abusif l'exercice qui était fait
du droit de grève
le différend vous savez entre pilotes et
direction de la compagnie aérienne porte
toujours sur le même problème
le pilotage à 2 et non plus à 3 pour le
nouvel avion airbus a320 geneviève mans
voici l'objet du litige
la cabine de pilotage de l'airbus a320
elle est conçue pour des pilotes
les pilotes d'air inter demande
l'adjonction pour des raisons de
sécurité deux mécaniciens
pour faire pression sur la direction en
ce sens les syndicats sauf la cfdt avait
déposé un préavis de grève pour le 24
novembre le tribunal de grande instance
de bobigny statuant en référé a déclaré
ce matin la grève
il y six motifs l'autre compagnies dans
le monde font voler leurs avions à deux
pilotes s'ils accèdent aux
revendications de ces syndicats air
inter risque de n'être plus compétitive
en conséquence le tribunal estime que je
cite les syndicats envisagent d'exercer
leur droit de grève d'une manière
abusive et crée un trouble manifestement
illicite qu'il convient en l'état de
faire cesser ce jugement comme celui du
tribunal de créteil en juillet dernier
sur la même affaire peut être
interprétés comme une remise en cause du
droit de grève
les arguments qui sont pris avancées
technologiques concurrence
internationale compétition mais ils
peuvent s'appliquer à tout mouvement
revendicatif
la question qui est posée c'est les
salariés dorénavant d'oeuvre ont-ils
demandé l'autorisation au juge avant
d'exercer la mission que leur a confié
la constitution le comme le législateur
l'a précisé
c'était le fruit de longues batailles au
cours des années c'est tout ça qu'on va
jeter dehors aux orties la direction de
l'inter a pris acte de la décision du
tribunal et réaffirme la volonté de
poursuivre les négociations sur l'avenir
des mécaniciens
elle souligne par ailleurs que le 24
novembre
tous les avions prévus voleront encore
une affaire qui se politise trois
responsables d'une station fm radio
nostalgie sont actuellement en prison à
lyon pour faux usage de faux et abus de
biens sociaux la faire c'est donc
politisé hier soir lorsque le juge
d'instruction a convoqué le responsable
du parti socialiste du rhône monsieur
deschamps qui s'est donc rendu au palais
de justice mais qui en est reparti
quatre heures plus tard sans avoir été
entendus rachida quelles étaient les
relations entre pierre alberti le
directeur de radio nostalgie inculpé il
ya deux jours
et yvon deschamps secrétaire de la
fédération socialiste du rhône
le juge chargé du dossier radio
nostalgie n'a pas pu le savoir
la nuit dernière le juge fennecs a en
effet quitté le palais de justice de
lyon en colère il voulait entendre le
responsable socialiste yvon deschamps et
cela dans le cadre de l' enquête sur les
malversations financières commises par
les dirigeants de radio nostalgie mais
le parquet a estimé que des faits
nouveaux venait d'apparaître
c'est pour cette raison officielle
qu'yvon deschamps est sortie du tribunal
après quatre heures d'attenté sans avoir
rencontré le juge qui l'avait convoqué
été entendu par aucun juge marocain n'a
juste pas par aucun procureur voilà il
ya votre avis volonté de politiser cette
affaire avec votre garde à vue
aujourd'hui l'objet la question juge
je ne sais pas si certains parlent déjà
d'affaires politique c'est tout
simplement qu'yvon deschamps est un
proche de charles hernu alors l'ancien
ministre de la défense serait il à
nouveau sur la sellette
en tout cas le maire de villeurbanne ne
quitte plus la une des journaux depuis
quelques temps déjà les simples faits
dont il ne faut bien sûr tirer aucune
conséquence hâtive surtout lorsqu'il
s'agit l'honneur d'un homme montre donc
une nouvelle fois que cette affaire
touche un ami de charles hernu et
l'ancien ministre de la défense
socialiste qui admet plutôt mal d'être à
nouveau mais les un dossier plus que
délicat dans la panade sur la pression
seulement n'a que l'on me fait une sorte
de procès en sorcellerie
je suis un peu désemparés dans ce cas
moi je suis un homme dont la sincérité
je crois n'a d'égal que le courage et la
fidélité quoi tout ça j'ai entendu
monsieur fabius ce premier ministre
lance un communiste dire une affaire
deux affaires bon ça fait trop pour un
seul ministère c'est donc plus un
journaliste vous met en cause c'est
quelqu'un du parti socialiste côté
l'otan a eu pendant cinq ans comme moi
autant de dossiers à connaître
j'en connais beaucoup j'en ai traité
beaucoup j'ai mené beaucoup d'actions et
moi je ne dis rien moi je suis discret
je suis même secret et pourtant j'en
connais si j'en parlais il serait de
nature à générer entre deux genres vous
avez envie un jour ou l'autre de réagir
et peut-être de sortir de votre réserve
et de dire des choses qui serait une
sorte de contre attaque
je ne sortirai pas demain réserve contre
le deux bars d'état et contre le respect
que je dois aux forces en vue de ce pays
et en cette matière je trouve que des
gens qui parlent trop je ne serai pas de
ceux là
en attendant de connaître la décision de
françois mitterrand candidat ou non à la
prochaine élection présidentielle
certains postulants à la candidature
socialiste comme jean pierre chevènement
s'impatienter et regrette le silence
actuel du ps et ils ont choisi de
s'exprimer à l'occasion du comité
directeur qui se tient aujourd'hui et
demain à paris bernard pradines
inquiétudes de certains au parti
socialiste pourquoi parler de nouvel
équilibre c'est à dire tenir compte de
l'expérience du pouvoir mais avec le
risque de dérive droitière à droite
monsieur de l'or absent aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs monsieur bérégovoy monsieur
jospin et même monsieur mitterrand il
faut se compter à gauche réclament
monsieur chevènement et le prochain
président s'il est des nôtres donnera
dissoudre l'assemblée
ajoute le député de belfort suivi de
près par monsieur poperen réponses
rassurantes de monsieur jospin
le projet du candidat socialiste on
connaîtra le moment venu restera fidèle
à une stratégie de gauche sur regard et
ses amis discret tout au long de ce
débat se retrouve d'une certaine façon
au sens d'un parti socialiste bon les
crânes à bienne en paix sur plus de la
côte ascendante de monsieur bas dans les
sondages à six mois de l'élection
présidentielle
le crédit agricole doit-il être un cas
particulier cette question a été l'objet
d'un débat difficile à l'assemblée
nationale et pas seulement entre
opposition et majorité
mais au sein même de la majorité en
schématisant il y a ceux qui souhaitent
que les bénéfices de la mutualisation du
crédit
ricol profitent aux agriculteurs et les
autres qui sont contre cette dérogation
à la loi commune le vote vient d'avoir
lieu
geneviève le débat a été houleux hier
soir les députés socialistes ont réussi
à repousser le vote du projet de loi sur
la mutualisation du crédit agricole
parce que le quorum n'était pas atteint
aujourd'hui les toutes les banques
n'étaient pas plus remplis mais les
ténors étaient là le projet de loi donc
été adopté par 325 voix contre 248
cette loi prévoit la transformation de
la caisse nationale de crédit agricole
en société anonyme avant son rachat à
90% par les 84 caisses régionales
les 10 % restant étant réservés au
personnel de la caisse
les socialistes et les communistes ont
voté contre le projet estimant qu'il
s'agit là d'une privatisation déguisée
de la banque des agriculteurs
le principal point d'achoppement a été
la destination des 6 à 10 milliards de
francs issus de cette mutualisation
fonds qui devrait entrer dans le compte
spécial et privatisations que le prix de
la caisse nationale serve au moins aux
agriculteurs et qu'il revienne en
particulier pour faire une opération de
désendettement des agriculteurs en
difficulté et pour aussi finances et de
la modernisation agricole
jacques chirac a autorisé françois
guillaume le ministre de l'agriculture à
prendre l'engagement qu'au moins une
partie de cet argent qui reste au
secteur agricole et agroalimentaire
à votre avis quand aura lieu la
prochaine élection en france en mai 88
faut vous avez perdu mais en revanche
vous avez gagné le droit de savoir
quelle aura lieu le 9 décembre prochain
il s'agit des élections au tribunal des
prud'hommes qui règlent les conflits
entre patrons et salariés
c'est un exemple de cohabitation sociale
remarquable en france mais qui ne
provoque pas il faut le dire au moment
du scrutin
l'enthousiasmé des électeurs puisque en
moyenne 50% s'abstiennent ali
aujourd'hui la cfdt lancé sa campagne
pour ces élections prud'homales
véronique auger
non edmond maire n'est pas candidat ni
aux présidentielles ni aux prud'hommes
les candidats au poste de conseiller
prud'homal ce sont eux on sent sur la
région nord pas de calais quatorze mille
en france deux fois le nombre de postes
à pourvoir
mais c'est une mère a jugé bon de se
déplacer à lille et surtout de faire
plus d'une heure de discours c'est que
l'actualité sociale l'exigent pour la
cfdt le jugement de bobigny une brèche
dans laquelle le patron d'havas
s'engouffre dans ce pays s'il ya un type
de délinquance qui n'est pas
suffisamment et primes et c'est bien là
d un conte social d'origine patronale
être objectif n'est pas de mettre en
brisant le maximum de chefs d'entreprise
possible il est de faire en sorte que
les patrons respecte pleinement les
libertés syndicales dans ce pays où il
faudra bien que les patrons se met à
jour avec leur temps et deviennent enfin
des démocrates
edmond maire a quand même rappelé à
l'ordre les syndicalistes
pas de bataille entre les syndicats
élite et où parasitage politique être
beaucoup plus proche des gens
manifestation cet après midi à 4 après
le meurtre d'un algérien par deux
parachutistes c'était au début de cette
semaine thierry calmont il avait une
sale gueule c'est le prétexte invoqué
par les deux parachutistes du 8e rpima
pour le meurtre de senouci bouchiba
mardi dernier ce crime raciste a secoué
la population de castres ce matin plus
de 15 cents personnes ont défilé en
ville dans le calme
tous quel que soit leur âge ou leur
origine proclament leur indignation
ça dépasse les 2000 un bouclier qui l'a
le nombre des vies reconnu surpris vous
ce qu'ils ont fait surtout quand le
pointage était fausse
en plus c'est à deux qu'ils y sont allés
la manifestation n'avait pas
l'autorisation de défiler devant la
caserne du 8e rpima où les militaires
sont toujours consigné alors les
manifestants et les élus municipaux sont
allés fleurir l'endroit où senoussi
bouchiba est tombé sous les coups de
couteau
la démonstration s'est achevée dans le
calme les deux parachutistes inculpé
d'homicide volontaire demeure incarcéré
à la prison d'albi la police confirme
c'est bien max frérot le spécialiste en
explosif des terroristes d'action
directe qui a été aperçu jeudi dernier
dans un parking du 15e arrondissement à
paris
il s'est trouvé face à face avec deux
vigiles il en a blessé un d'un coup de
revolver avant de réussir à prendre la
fuite dans la sphère du rapt de la
petite mélodie en espagne la coopération
entre les polices française et espagnole
a permis l'arrestation à paris de cinq
personnes qui ferait partie du gang
international qui avait mise au point
cet enlèvement qui s'est heureusement
bien terminée
d'autres arrestations pourraient avoir
de luigi facchinetti ce redoutable
gangster italien qui le 18 octobre
dernier avait tué un gendarme et un
douanier français à la frontière franco
suisse a été à son tour abattu dans la
région de brescia par des policiers
italiens et cela au terme d'une course
poursuite en voiture dans le coffre du
véhicule de facchinetti on a découvert
un véritable arsenal à nice par hold up
meurtre évasion facchinetti était
recherché par toutes les polices de
suisse de france et d'italie mais d'hier
soir une fusillade éclate à brescia dans
le nord de l'italie entre des policiers
et les occupants d'une voiture qui tente
de s'enfuir père luigi facchinetti et
tué sur le coup
son complice grièvement blessé est dans
la voiture on retrouve un véritable
arsenal
on le soupçonne d'être l'auteur du hold
up sanglant qui avait coûté la vie à
trois personnes en septembre dernier au
club le topless à pigalle
il était recherché également pour la
fusillade au péage de viry en haute
savoie au mois d'octobre un douanier et
un gendarme avait été tué
considérés en suisse comme l'ennemi
public numéro un facchinetti faisait
parler de lui pour ses hold up mais
aussi pour ses évasions à répétition des
pénitenciers suisse incarcéré à la
prison de fresnes près de paris
ils s'en étaient échappées il ya deux
ans le plus tranquillement du monde par
la porte son frère venu lui rendre
visite avait pris sa place dans sa
cellule derniers éléments de l'enquète
sur l' incendie du métro de londres
ce ne serait pas une cigarette qui
serait à l'origine de la catastrophe
mais un échauffement déroulement d'un
escalier mécanique en bois le feu aurait
couvé sous l'escalier avant de se
déclarer donc à l'étranger deux
informations seulement à retenir
aujourd'hui à beyrouth d'abord le cheikh
fadlallah chef religieux chiite pro
iranien est très influent au liban
déclare que le sort des otages
occidentaux du liban a peu de chances
d'être réglée avant les élections
présidentielles françaises et
américaines et que le sort de ces hommes
n'est plus dans les mains des libanais
de quelque bord qu'ils sont et puis
l'accord survenu entre le président
reagan et le congrès américain pour
réduire le déficit du budget des états
unis 2 76 milliards de dollars en deux
ans est accueilli avec optimisme et avec
prudence tout de même par les financiers
en effet la bourse de new york la bourse
wall street n'a enregistré qu'une légère
hausse
le bon point de cette semaine où le
décernons à une pme française
la société baigner
signé d'arras plus exactement qui va
bitume et la première autoroute chinoise
la société n'en est pas à son coup
d'essai puisqu'en france elle compte
déjà à son actif deux mille kilomètres
d'autoroutes et la particularité de
cette entreprise c'est qu'elle fabrique
elle même ces matériels florence malik
non cette mâchoire d'acier n'est pas la
dernière trouvaille de mad max
c'est plus simplement l'énorme rotor de
la recette sans un engin unique en son
genre spécialement conçu pour rénover
les routes
un tank version pour et chaussées qui a
déjà permis à bonnier de remettre à neuf
une bonne partie du réseau routier
français
la pme tente désormais une percée vers
l'étranger après la hollande tous les
chemins mènent à pékin baignée par la
conquête des chinois il se trouve que
dans leur province
ils ont un réseau considérable de voies
secondaires qui sont dans un état assez
lamentable je dois dire est qu'ils ont
et qui réclament des techniques très
simple très pragmatique
une fois en action lac 700 ne se
contente pas d'un lifting du revêtement
goudronné il laboure la chaussée en
profondeur il fait ou qu'on casse malaxe
et nivelles en même temps
associé à son frère siamois le camion
doseur de ciment l'arc 700 fait du neuf
avec du vieux
dernier né de la gamme baigner cet engin
permet d'abaisser de 30% le coût de
remise en état d'une route
un argument de poids pour cette pme qui
mise avant tout sur l'innovation pour
imposer son savoir faire avec en ligne
de mire une robe transformé dès 1992 en
un gigantesque noeud routier unis dès
maintenant pour votre samedi soir ou
pour votre dimanche soir une valeur sûre
qui ne se démode pas il s'agit pas de
bourse mais de théâtre lyrique
l'opérette avec l'inusable offenbach au
théâtre de paris
titre du livre est le pont des soupirs
lieu venise metteur en scène jean michel
ribes qui entend bien remettre au goût
du jour ce qu'il appelle la bouffonnerie
française par rapport à l'humour anglais
ou encore aux gags à l'amérique
nicole cornu landois ivre
pari gagné pour cette équipe qui fait
triompher aujourd'hui encore l'opéra
bouffe grâce les atouts classique
d'offenbach
le couple qui vocalise la musique au
service du rire et le coeur qui
commentent quiproquos et rebondissements
avec en plus le délire décapant d'un
metteur en scène qui n'a peur d'aucun
effet ni d'aucun accès et qui redonne
vie à venir j'ai voulu que la folie
extraordinairement débridée de l'oeuvre
la drôlerie infinie est tellement belle
de l'oeuvre ne soit pas ne soit pas
bloqué par quelques petites poussières
due à des références dont on a oublié
les clés c'est tout mais les les
cinquante chanteurs comédiens musiciens
même plus qui sont sur ce plateau je
veux dire joue 909 danse humeur qui est
tellement drôle et tellement belle que
elle est intemporelle et ça je crois
qu'on en a vraiment besoin aujourd'hui
le sport maintenant avec juste un rappel
le français fabien canu champion du
monde de judo et puis brigitte deydier
médaille d'argent toujours aux
championnats du monde de judo
et puis en tennis dans le masters
féminin à new york navratilova a été
battue en quarts de finale par
l'argentine sabatini et au classement
des joueurs français yannick noah malgré
sa blessure reprend la première place à
henri leconte les résultats du tiercé
d'aujourd'hui maintenant qui vont
s'inscrire sur votre écran pour gagner
il fallait jouer le 6 le 11 et le 12
et puis maintenant les pronostics de
demain pierrette brès a choisi le cadre
du salon du cheval s'était approprié à
la porte de versailles
sans du sam se déroulent actuellement
les journées internationales du pur sang
arabe le championnat demandera
lundi prochain car seconde demain après
midi à auteuil dans le prix prince
d'ecouen il s'agit d'une course de haies
handicap réservé au jury
âgés de 5 ans et plus ils seront 15 à
prendre le départ de ce tiercé ce sont
tous des spécialistes des dogons ans qui
viennent d'ailleurs aussi dans le
pronostic que je vous propose maintenant
eh bien j'ai choisi de faire tout
d'abord confiance aux favoris alors en
tête de ma sélection
j'ai choisi de mettre perceval et c'est
le numéro 7 suivi du très sport
4 donc la nuit
iman détenu
or dit tenir de grands viviers
mais roddick en boy le flingue
numéro vite pour terminer je réponds
7 4 1
et tout de suite la météo j'osais un
avant goût de l'hiver daniel demain avec
écoutez plutôt au programme une baisse
des températures beaucoup de nuages de
la pluie et de la neige alors c'est une
perturbation qui nous vient du nord qui
sera la grande responsable de toute
cette agitation
donc résultat demain cette perturbation
sera à la mi-journée sur les trois
quarts du pays c'est à dire sur la
vendée si je peux avoir la carte la
vendée l'aquitaine les pyrénées mais
aussi les alpes champagne ardenne donc
voici cette zone qui demain sera
couverte de nuages
il y aura aussi de la pluie de la neige
à partir de 1000 m en revanche il fera
beau dans le midi et il y aura un clin
d'oeil du soleil sur le nord-ouest dans
l'après midi les températures sont en
baisse vous allez voir 7° à nancy et à
dijon sur la moitié sud 6 degrés
seulement à grenoble et à lyon et demain
dimanche 22 novembre ce sera la fête du
christ roi
instituée par le pape pie ix 11%
beaulize et le jour où le christ sera
croix de l'univers voilà avant de nous
quitter juste une petite publicité pour
l'émission qui suit champs-elysées avec
ce soir un plateau éblouissant puisque
l'invité principal et michel sardou
qu'il y aura également un hommage aux
beatles et qu'il y aura également birgit
nilsson c'est l'ex madame stallone qui
en a sûrement eu assez de son
intellectuelle demain et puis tout à
l'heure en fin de programme un garçon
qui est pas mal non plus c'est philippe
gassot qui vous présentera les dernières
informations bonsoir excellente soirée à
demain 13h